among the latest most wanted fugitives
are alleged gangsters a gun supplier
drug traffickers and two men suspected
of murder
nanarapong is wanted for a drive-by
shooting in essex of a man police think
was a gang rival the victim died from
eight gunshots
callum halpin allegedly shot dead a drug
dealer in manchester five others have
already been convicted of the murder
buenos dias
the new campaign was launched in madrid
spanish officials were joined by their
british counterparts in an appeal for
the public's help
one thing is for sure
sometimes it's incredibly difficult for
people to come forward because those
criminals are close to home too close to
home sometimes there may be family there
may be friends but people
generally want to do the right thing
spain has long been a haven for british
fugitives though the introduction of pan
eu european arrest warrants meant they
could be brought home swiftly
after brexit the warrant system was
scrapped but a new deal means those on
the run when caught can be extradited
just as easily
in spain
for quite some time we've got quite a
significant expatriate community that
exists
and we find that these offenders will
seek to blend within those communities
and of course spain is close to the uk
easy to travel to
and you know is a pleasant people is a
pleasant place to locate themselves asim
naveed is from cardiff
in the city and across wales he's
thought to have distributed nearly eight
million pounds worth of cocaine during
the first covet lockdown
he and associates use the encroachat
encrypted phone system with its built-in
delete button according to police
two years ago hundreds of suspects were
arrested after detectives cracked the
encrypted phone codes
scotsman james stevenson is wanted for
various crimes including arson
and for importing cocaine hidden inside
produce destined for glasgow fruit
market
dean garforth is wanted by cheshire
police for guns and drug supply in the
northwest of england part of a
well-known organized crime gang
it's been six years since the last most
wanted campaign around british fugitives
in spain they were very successful of
the 96 suspects who were featured 86
were tracked down arrested and
extradited to the uk
anybody with information about the
suspects is urged to alert police or
contact anonymously the charity crime
stoppers uk
martin brunt sky news